l'aspirine pour prévenir mais surtout
pour soigner l'infarctus simple mais
vérifiez l'aspirine est aussi efficace
après les crises cardiaques la réaction
des palestiniens de l'ol paie après la
décision du roi hussein ibrahim sousse
son représentant à paris s'explique dans
ce journal
sur la route de séoul les jeux
olympiques approchent premier meeting
européen d'été à sestrières avec les
stars américaines en vedette carl lewis
et ben johnson rostropovitch à perpignan
c'était l'un des clous du festival
méditerranéen
le maître dirigé hier soir lors qu est
de washington
bonsoir est d'abord cet espoir pour tous
les cardiaques il faut savoir qu'en
france chaque année l'infarctus la crise
cardiaque tue près de cent mille
personnes
on savait depuis quelques temps que
l'aspirine était un bon médicament pour
la prévention des maladies du coeur
on sait maintenant qu'il peut servir
aussi dans le traitement après
l'infarctus
après la crise il faut dans ce cas
l'associé à un autre médicament
c'est le résultat d'une enquête
internationale très sérieuse portant sur
plus de 17 mille malades
les conclusions de cette enquête
viennent d'être publiées à londres jean
daniel flaysakier jean-jacques le garrec
répondu oui je me suis trouvé cette
souris ou mad men être à table alors
j'ai voulu me reposer mais le douleurs
au ventre et dans le dos aux époux rue
les bras et puis alors si vous traversez
la poitrine et puis ça mais gagné le
mexique
et puis transpiration un bond à la
douleur de germaine crise était celle
d'un infarctus du myocarde étape ultime
de l'obstruction des artères coronaires
qui nourrissent le muscle cardiaque
ces artères se bougent progressivement à
course de dépôt de graisse ce qu'on
appelle latéraux mme et puis un jour de
cette plaque d'athérome se détache un
petit caillou qui va se promener dans
les vaisseaux jusqu'au moment où il va
venir obstruant une artère plus petit
le sang ne passe plus le muscle
cardiaque moeurs et l'infarctus pour
réduire le nombre de morts à la suite
d'un infarctus 400 hôpitaux à travers le
monde se sont associés pour étudier un
nouveau mode de traitement
dix sept mille malades ont ainsi reçu
dès leur arrivée à l'hôpital
un comprimé d'aspirine et ce pendant un
mois et une dose unique d'un produit à
peu les streptocoques naze c'est un film
tiré d'une bactérie permet de dissoudre
le caillot très rapidement en une heure
environ
alors que l'aspirine donné pendant tout
le mois et vite que se reconstituent une
nouvelle plaque d'athérome et qu'un
nouveau caillou puisse ainsi migré
au bout du compte alors qu'avec les
traitements conventionnels près de 13 %
des malades meurent dans les cinq
premières semaines suivant l'accident
grâce à ce traitement strict qui n'a
plus aspirine seuls 8% des malades sont
morts
un traitement qui pourrait apparaître
comme miraculeux mais en fait il n'en
est rien car s'il n'est pas appliquée à
temps ce traitement ne sert à rien
il faut que les gens comprennent qu'il
faut venir très vite dans un centre de
soins qu'il s'agisse d'une clinique
qu'il s'agisse d'un hôpital et peut-être
bientôt directement par le samu et que
le traitement soit commencer le plus tôt
possible
l'infarctus puissant mille français par
an dont 40 milles entre 40 et 65 ans
avec cette nouvelle technique aspirine
plus très tôt kinases on peut espérer
sauver 5000 à 7000 personnes
mais si les français fument et moins
manger moins de graisses animales
faisait plus d'exercice on n'en
changerai encore beaucoup plus pour le
sida la recherche médicale apporte
chaque jour un nouvel espoir aujourd'hui
cependant il faut rester très très
prudent avec la nouvelle expérimentation
menée par les américains
l'utilisation d'une molécule reproduite
par génie génétique
il faut être très prudent car nous n'en
sommes qu'au tout début de
l'expérimentation et il ya déjà eu
beaucoup de faux espoirs en ce domaine
alain labouze la cible du virus du sida
c'est cette cellule un globule blanc
spécialisé dans la défense de
l'organisme sur son enveloppe
cette petite zone en rouge constitue la
porte d'entrée pour le virus qui va se
multiplier à l'intérieur de la cellule
et provoqué la chute des défenses
immunitaires
les américains ont réussi à produire
artificiellement la réplique exacte de
cette zone en rouge une molécule appelée
cd4 ce que les chercheurs espèrent c'est
que le virus fera une erreur en se
trompant de cible les globules blancs
pourraient être épargnés
l'idée est séduisante sur le plan
théorique mais attention il est encore
beaucoup trop tôt pour parler d'un
nouveau médicament contre le sida
il faudra d'abord attendre les résultats
d'une expérimentation sur l'homme qui
vient seulement de démarrer aux états
unis première réaction des palestiniens
après la décision du roi hussein il y a
dix jours le roi avait annoncé la
rupture des liens entre son pays la
jordanie et la cisjordanie territoire
occupé par israël depuis cette annonce
les palestiniens de l'ol paie était
resté très discret on sait aujourd'hui
qu'ils vont réunir le conseil national
palestinien en algérie alger a donné son
accord
et puis ibrahim sousse le représentant
de l'ol est à paris a expliqué tout à
l'heure à geneviève moll ce que les
palestiniens attendaient de ce conseil
le conseil national va développer toutes
ces hypothèses tu as étudié en
profondeur toutes les possibilités qui
maintenant s'ouvre à nous après la
démarche du roi roussel et et nous
allons décider laquelle est la meilleure
pour aboutir à une paix juste et durable
dans les respect des droits de tous dans
l'âge une paix juste et durable ça veut
dire un état palestinien
bien entendu les pgc libérable dans le
respect des droits de tout le monde à
commencer par le peuple palestinien dont
les droits continuent à être bafouée et
qui demande à ce que ses droits soient
reconnus dans leur intégralité
la décision du roi hussein va vous aider
dans le dialogue que vous tentez avec
les israéliens
il est certain que la décision de roi en
scène a été bien accueilli par
l'ensemble de la population
palestinienne parce qu'elle donne
souffle nouveau à un soulèvement
populaire palestinien et à la lutte
palestinienne en général parce que
maintenant des israéliens sont accumulés
à reconnaître face à eux qui est une
question palestinienne qui ne peuvent
résoudre avec les palestiniens eux mêmes
ne peut pas tergiverser allez dire nous
allons résoudre ça avec la jordanie ou
avec l'egypte où avec la syrie en face
d'eux les palestiniens ils doivent
discuter avec ces palestiniens du
problème palestinien
après quand la birmanie en pleine
tourmente selon des touristes qui
viennent de se réfugier en thaïlande
rangoon la capitale bergame ressemble
maintenant un champ de bataille la
capitale birmane bien sûr après quatre
jours d'affrontements entre manifestants
et forces de l'ordre
le bilan est déjà très lourd jacques
merlino de ce pays l'un des plus fermés
du monde nous parviennent que très peu
d'image seulement ces quelques plans
filmé clandestinement et qui montre
l'importance des manifestations puis
depuis plusieurs jours ce coup là
birmanie
aujourd'hui à rangoon la capitale on
évalue à près de 400 morts le nombre de
manifestants tués par l'armée où la
police
selon certaines rumeurs il y aurait dans
plusieurs villes de province mutineries
au sein de l'armée et parfois alliance
entre soldats et manifestants
il n'apparaît pas actuellement qu'il y
est un dirigeant à la tête de ce
mouvement
simplement une population excédée par un
régime totalitaire qui frise la paranoïa
et qui en 26 années de dictature
mélangeant marxisme et pouvoir militaire
à transformer un pays riche par ses
ressources pétrolières et agricoles ans
l'un des cinq pays les plus pauvres du
monde
c'est la misère qui finalement aura
réussi à réveiller ce peuple de
tradition passive et qui forme avec ses
200 milles bronze
l'une des premières communautés
bouddhistes dans cette situation confuse
qui prend de plus en plus l'alluré d'une
insurrection
il faut encore rappeler que le régime
birman est en lutte depuis des années
contre divers mouvements de guérilla le
tiers du territoire est actuellement
entre leurs mains et l'on ne compte pas
moins de douze ethnies insurgé contre le
pouvoir central
la plus célèbre étant celle des carènes
installés le long de la frontière
thaïlandaise selon les derniers
témoignages de touristes venant de
quitter la birmanie la capitale
ressemblerait ce soir un véritable champ
de bataille parsemé de barricades et le
ravitaillement en eau et en nourriture
serait des plus précaires en asie encore
d'autres affrontements c'est en corée du
sud cette fois dans un peu plus d'un
mois les jeux olympiques vont commencer
à séoul mais les troubles continuent
dans ce pays des milliers d'étudiants
manifestent ils ont lancé un mouvement
pour l'unification des deux corées la
police a procédé à de multiples
arrestations
jérôme boni
à 40 jours des jeux olympiques de
véritables batailles rangées se déroule
encore aujourd'hui dans plusieurs ville
sud coréenne
les étudiants qui veulent la
réunification des deux corées ont décidé
de se rendre coûte que coûte le 15 août
à panmunjom ville frontière pour
rencontrer leurs camarades du nord une
rencontre interdite par le gouvernement
de séoul
cette réunion pourrait troubler le
climat nécessaire au déroulement des
jeux olympiques des brigades
d'intervention spécialement entraînés on
entendre d'empêcher à tout prix la
progression des étudiants vers la
frontière près de 800 d'entre eux ont
été interpellés hier à la suite d'
attaques contre 12 commissariat de
police ces incidents ne sont pas dus au
hasard les deux corées près par des
pourparlers
les premiers depuis trois ans le 17 août
à l'ordre du jour la participation de la
corée du nord à l'organisation des jeux
et un pacte de non agression pour les
dirigeants sud-coréens une priorité le
17 septembre il faudra que séoul soir
devenue une capitale pacifique pour
recevoir la flamme olympique
oui pendant ce temps là les athlètes se
préparent et les records commencent déjà
à tomber en natation l'un des plus
prestigieux était battu la nuit dernière
aux états unis au cours des sélections
américaines à austin au texas matt
biondi a pulvérisé le record du monde du
100 m nage libre 48 secondes 42
centièmes en athlétisme on ne bat pas
les records mais en les frôlent pour
leur première apparition dans les
meetings européens l'été les américains
encore eux ont été brillants c'était à
sestrières en italie une station
d'altitude très propice aux records
elle est à 2050 m si vous n'avez pas vu
ses superbes images sur antenne 2 cet
après midi regardez le français stéphane
caristan n'est plus recordman d'europe
du 110 m haies
ce record le britannique colin jackson
s'en est emparé en 13 secondes 11
centièmes mais la course a été dominée
de bout en bout par rogers kingdom
l'américain en short rouge au cinquième
couloir
sont en 12 secondes 97 centièmes
meilleure performance de l'année
kingdon et le deuxième athlète au monde
à descendre sous les 13 secondes au 110
m e et ce champion olympique approche de
quatre centièmes le record du monde un
record qu'il se dit prêt à faire tomber
dès maintenant sur le 200 m l'américain
carl lewis se prépare à faire cavalier
seul mais le français gilles quénéhervé
sélectionnés pour séoul va tirer son
épingle du jeu
à l'arrivée 19 secondes 82 centièmes
pour lewis le deuxième meilleur temps de
sa carrière à 10 centièmes du record du
monde en deuxième position non pas
l'américain calvin smith champion du
monde en titre mais le français
quénéhervé au 7e couloir 20 secondes 20
centièmes il approche de quatre
centièmes son record de france
carl lewis fort satisfait de son temps
tandis qu'au sens battre l'insatiable
ben johnson s'avoue un peu déçu le
canadien a visé les neuf secondes 80
centièmes il réalise 18 centièmes de
plus 9 secondes 98 quand même le
deuxième meilleur temps de l'année
des performances qui en font deviner
d'autres probablement dès la semaine
prochaine au meeting de zurich en france
en politique une petite phrase de
philippe seguin qui risque de faire de
grandes vagues l'ancien ministre rpr
affirme dans un entretien publié par le
nouvel observateur que le rpr a autre
chose à dire et à faire que de soutenir
les candidatures présidentielle de
jacques chirac fin de citation philippe
seguin passe déjà pour le chef de file
des rénovateurs au sein du rpr on attend
maintenant la réponse des chiraquiens
gardanne reprise tendue ce matin trois
jours après la médiation du ministère de
l'industrie et trois mois après le début
du conflit il y a eu même des incidents
entre militants cgt et cfdt
à la reprise donc un conflit en tout cas
qui laissera des traces
emmanuel vanier a partagé la vie d'un
mineur en ce jour de reprise
reportage
bernard osinski 33 ans 6 ans domine
salaires 6500 francs mensuels il est
syndiquée à la cgt
les quatre mois de grève il les a vécues
l'abat jour et nuit sur le carreau de la
mine en quatre mois une semaine
seulement passés à la maison martin sa
femme élève les trois enfants elle a été
de toutes les manifestations un soutien
constant malgré une vie de famille
bouleversée et d'importantes difficultés
financières
fally rems la nourriture se payer juste
et l'essentiel pour elle et les lilas
auprès petty la viande
regardez ce qu'on prenait non triés
alors comment ça s'est passé des enfants
c'était dur pour nous c'est un louis
zanon énormément souffert il n'avait
plus de vie de famille
il voyait pas leur père j'étais souvent
à la mine ont les deux grands il
rentrait de l'école ce n'est pas là le
petit et tout temps chez une voisine
ils ont énormément souffert le jour où
je leur ai dit ça y est la grève est
finie mon dieu nous allons pleurer
n'était pas possible
ce matin la reprise du travail pas
d'extraction de charbon aujourd'hui mais
des tâches d'entretien et de remise en
état des machines
après quatre mois de conflit l'envié de
retourner au fond à moins 700 m ça fait
quatre mois qu'on attend ce jour
je compte me rendre chez moi on est
mineur de père en fils je m'en aille à
un père était mineur au grand père mon
père est heureux on prend de travail
très heureux de ce corps
même si en fait roland
mais encore assez forte quand même hein
bien grâce à la solidarité
les autres
la solidarité c'est ce qui leur a permis
de tenir quatre mois entre 200 et 400
francs de dons chaque semaine l'ambiance
était tendue ce matin sur le carreau
entre grévistes et non grévistes mais
dans deux semaines tout sera effacée
disait bernard la solidarité du fond
aura effacé les rancoeurs la colère de
la picardie les habitants damier on
décide de dire on décide et pardon de
réagir après l annonce officielle du
tracé du tgv nord qui ne passera pas par
leur ville ils ont décidé de vendre le
terrain sur lequel doit passer le tgv en
de multiples parcelles d'un mètre carré
succès immédiate pour cette opération
reste bien sûr à savoir si cette révolte
va réellement retardé les travaux de la
sncf michel mompontet depuis hier sur la
place de la gare d'amiens étrange vente
à la criée
en effet l'association amiens tgv devant
des parcelles de terrain situées sur le
parcours même du futur tgv nord ce
parcours qu'ils combattent parce que
justement il évite leur ville le but de
cette vente de terrains à 10 francs
retarder la construction de cette ligne
maudite pour eux et compliquer la tâche
de l'état par des centaines
d'expropriation supplémentaires c'est
éphémère propriétaires sont ce soir au
nombre de 1000 notre démarche est légale
sinon nous ne le ferions pas la sncf ne
peut acquérir des terrains que lorsque
la déclaration d'utilité publique est
prononcé comme l épreuve prononcer fin
ne se fera pas avant six mois ne pouvons
faire tout les acquisitions que nous
voulons aujourd'hui aucun problème nous
gagnerons parce que nous luttons contre
une minorité qui nous gouvernent
il est anormal que cette technocratie
gagne contre toute une population
donc nous sommes confiants
confiant sûrement optimiste peut être un
peu trop en effet ces mille
expropriations n'auront pratiquement
aucune chance de ralentir le tracé sncf
juste un peu plus de frais pour l'état
les actes sont reproduits carrément à la
photocopieuse et chaque fois ou à la
machine de traitement tête et chaque
fois il suffit simplement de remplir un
blanc en changeant le nom le numéro de
la parcelle et cetera donc ça rallonge
puis ça coûte plus cher puisque lorsque
vous faites une expropriation vous avez
un certain nombre d'actes qui doivent
être notifiée par lettre recommandée aux
propriétaires recommandée avec accusé de
réception
chaque fois ça coûte de l'argent les
quoi qu'il en soit des chances de succès
de cette opération
amiens est bien décidé à voir passer
coûte que coûte sur ses rails un tgv
l'automobile française en bonne santé le
marché redresse la tête set et demi
pourcent d'immatriculation plus en
juillet par rapport à juillet de l'année
dernière
voyons maintenant d'autres informations
de ce jeudi est tout d'abord des
nouvelles des marchés financiers car le
franc était un petit peu attaqué
aujourd'hui pascal deschamps ouf le
dollar baisse mais mauvaise surprise le
front est chahuté le billet vert a
baissé de près de 1% à 6 francs 42 85
contre 6 francs 48 70 mais la devise
française semble délaissé par les
cambistes
alléchés par des taux d'intérêts
ouest-allemand plus intéressant
c'est presque parti pour tf1 la nuit
dernière le premier satellite français
de télévision directe a pris l'avion
pour la base de qu après l'avion c'est
la fusée ariane qui l'emportera dans
l'espace le 7 octobre prochain
mais deux mois avant son lancement on ne
sait toujours pas quelle chaîne de
télévision il diffusera à nice benoît en
liberté sous contrôle judiciaire
cette sympathisante d'action directe
avait été condamné en février à 5 ans
d'emprisonnement pour association de
malfaiteurs mais la cour d'appel de
paris a estimé que cette accusation
n'est pas fondé à nice benoît reste
toutefois inculpé dans une affaire
d'attentât à l'explosif
niet c'est niet le militant arménien à
haïti on ne pourra pas revenir en urss
le présidium du soviet suprême n'est en
effet pas disposé à revenir sur sa
décision de l'expulser et de le déchoir
de sa nationalité soviétique et ce tant
qu'il continuera d'enfoncer par ses
activités
la constitution du pays
la direction de la sncf à l écoute des
syndicats s'étaient cet après midi à
paris il faut dire que ce matin encore
là ce matin encore donc la cgt avait de
nouveau accusé la sncf de mettre en
circulation des véhicules dangereux
cet après midi donc on discutait de la
sécurité entre direction et syndicats
après l'accident de train de la gare de
l'est et dans ce domaine bien sûr dans
le domaine de la sécurité il y a encore
beaucoup à dire
les participants viennent il y à
quelques minutes de sortir de la réunion
françoise joly suivait cette réunion sur
place tout de suite nous écoutons ce que
disait la sortie de la réunion le
directeur de la sncf
et bien la table ronde entre les sept
organisations syndicales et la direction
de la sncf aura donc duré plus de cinq
heures le directeur de la sncf vient de
sortir à l'instant de ces entretiens il
a annoncé trois types de mesures
les premières favorise le dialogue
social au sein de la sncf
en associant notamment le comité
d'entreprise aux réflexions d'un groupe
d'experts sur la sécurité les deuxième
mesure concerne la formation
il y aura désormais plus de journées de
formation pour les conducteurs enfin des
mesures techniques
je vous propose d'écouter un exemple
donné par le directeur général de la
sncf de d'accélérer le programme de mise
en oeuvre sur les locomotives et les
éléments automoteurs du système qui
permet automatiquement de couper le
courant
lorsque l'on freine ce qui permet par
conséquent de ne pas avoir des trains
qui à la fois frais et pousse ce qui ne
permet pas de s'arrêter dans de bonnes
conditions
toutes ces mesures n'ont pour l'instant
pas été chiffrée mais la direction de la
sncf fait là un geste significatif pour
calmer l'inquiétude syndicales de ces
derniers jours on voit tout ce que l'on
peut dire ce soir ici avec claude à la
direction de la sncf merci françois je
rappelle que vous étiez en direct de la
direction de la sncf où se tenait cet
après midi une importante réunion sur la
sécurité entre direction et syndicats
une nouvelle affaire de veau aux
hormones elle a éclaté en allemagne au
centre du scandale à très gros éleveurs
germanique qui a été arrêtée on découvre
aujourd'hui qu'il ay a sans doute un
véritable marché noir européen des
médicaments destinés à engraisser le
bétail des hormones bien sûr très nocif
pour la santé des consommateurs
la sphère s'étend maintenant à la
hollande nicolas jacobs un élevage
magnifique que celui de félix inc
14000 vaut le plus gros producteur de
rfa est un scandale en rapport au moins
4200 bête saisis chez lui été piqués aux
hormones
de quoi leur faire gagner 10 à 15 kg et
de quoi déclencher ce que le ministre
l'agriculture a qualifié de plus grand
scandale jamais découvert
rehefa il y a un important marché
clandestin hormone est il vraiment
nécessaire de mentionner la hollande
je n'en dirai pas plus cette affaire
ravive un vieux contentieux entre la rfa
et la hollande
les allemands accusant les hollandais de
ne pas appliquer vraiment les règles
communautaires règles qui interdisent
totalement les hormones et laisse à
chaque état le soin d'opérer les
contrôles ainsi accuse les allemands le
laxisme des hollandais a favorisé la
naissance d'un véritable trafic de
produits interdits
c'est donc la preuve qu'il faut
renforcer ses contrôles
l'europe doit vraiment faire appliquer
l'interdiction des hormones voté début
88 pour protéger les consommateurs
c'est la troisième affaire de ce type
qui éclate en allemagne mais pourtant
l'opinion publique semble maintenant si
être résigné si on savait tous qu'il met
dans une saucisse
on ne mangerait plus rien ça ne
l'empêchera pas de continuer à en
acheter quand j'achetais d'ubs aux
hormones
il ne m'arrive est rien alors pourquoi
ça changerait il n'empêche les 14000 vos
de monsieur wings seront abattus et leur
viande détruites
la mort de jean pierre ponnelle jean
pierre ponnelle c'était l'un des
metteurs en scène d'opéra les plus
connus ce français qui travaillaient
pour les plus grands opéras du monde
entier est mort à munich à l'âge de 56
ans ici il était filmé à paris il ya
trois ans lors d'une de ses mises en
scène du mariage de figaro de mozart la
voici
ponelle avait aussi travaillé avec les
plus grands chefs d'orchestre comme
karajan ou karl gomme rostropovitch à
perpignan c'était l'un des événements du
festival méditerranéen pendant deux mois
les plus grands solistes se sont succédé
sur la côte du jazz à l'opéra
rostropovitch à perpignan c'était hier
soir le maître diriger leurs caisses
nationales de washington
reportage gérard dalmat d' histoire
d'amour depuis 11 ans en preuve
ce propos beach et l' orchestre de
washington leurs enfants les concerts
sont de plus en plus réussie surtout
comme leur répertoire russe c'est à
l'honneur comme hier à perpignan
on dit que depuis que vous avez pris la
tête de l'orchestré de washington que
cet orchestre est devenu un des
meilleurs du monde
je ne sais pas demandez moi si vous
devez me disent tu de ton souffrir
j'ai pas demandé moi fait j'ai demandé
rouge après les concepts comme beaucoup
le pensaient mais c'est très bon ok
c'est en tout cas c'est sans doute ses
auteurs bref nous dresser 6b et pouvoir
aussi répertoire russe no des billets ce
soir c'est trottier construit et pour
bracci pense qu'ils seront coeur il y à
des lieux où la musique est aussi belle
à voir qu'à entendre exemple ce
majestueux palais des rois de majorque
alors le maître du violoncelle
abandonnent plus facilement l'archet
pour la baguette
il connaît des centaines de partition
par coeur les plus grandes composé pour
lui prokofiev bernstein chostakovitch et
pourtant tout de suite le courant passe
car cela va c'est son surnom conduit
comme il vit en passionnel
autour
est ce que vous y croyez à la glace
noces de la pérestroïka ce fait
important c'était son beau temps c'est
pas seulement pour sauver de ce métier
c'était cela pour tout le monde entière
très souvent la souffrance poli je pense
est très grand et très porté sur votre
mouvement
le nez de la question pas top non stop
continue t il sauf qu'aucun signe de
cette danse pour tous
rêvons un peu et pourquoi pas un jour à
moscou leur plastre de washington dirigé
par rostropovitch
m
ce serait le bouquet pour ce prince
russe en exil
j'ajoute qu'après perpignan c'est
montpellier ce soir pour rostropovitch
puis il jouera à marseille et le dernier
concert ce sera samedi à nice alors avis
aux amateurs qui refait il y avait un
tiercé aujourd'hui je vous donne les
résultats tout de suite c'était à
enghien 15 11 2 et 13 ça c'est pour le
quarté les rapports 1260 francs dans
l'ordre pour le tiercé et 17 1376
cependant l'or pour le quarté voit la
fin de ce journal le prochain rendez
vous avec l'information ce sera vers
23h40 la dernière édition présentée par
aubry et de l'air tout de suite vous
avez rendez vous avec laurent cabrol qui
est de plus en plus optimistes pour la
météo vous allez le voir
bonne soirée sur antenne 2 à demain soir
o o